so I believe that we are all wounded I
believe that we are all bleeding and I
think the reason that in romantic
contexts we are attracted to others who
are wounded is because we feel that by
saving them we in turn save ourselves
right romantic love is defined by Ernest
Becker is a perfect consummation with
perfection itself we are purged in these
instances in which we find another in
whose eyes we will be reflected and
saved right this notion that we are we
will see ourselves being seen by another
who bestows us with light and and off
ultimately the crux of the human
condition the existential impotence if
you will is the perhaps tragic
realization that you can't save the ones
you love those wounded birds the Manic
Pixie dream girl you can't save her so
what does that mean it means if you
can't even save the ones you love how
can you save yourself right this is the
tragedy of the human condition this is
the sad song that gives you the
goosebumps and makes you cry this is the
lyric that makes you tear up it is this
do knowledge mminton thing that aches of
something that is of something that we
wish was not the case
there is beauty in this tragedy but
first let us acknowledge the tragedy of
it and then and then you know we can
make a poem or make a video or make a
film to frame that holy moment to at
least cement the tragedy by saying it
happened we exist we felt something
talked about this before but that's why
we make art
city very 10 is a weekly series that
illuminates the life and beauty of a
city by capturing a series of
breathtaking intimate and eye-catching
moments from a single day shows the
amazing yet everyday elements and sites
that make places like Brooklyn Way no
site is and Mumbai feel like breathing
things
you